we're going to establish some rules that
we've kind of been using but we haven't
proven yet so now it's time to actually
say why we're doing some of the things
we're doing and why it works out so
conveniently so hopefully you've had
enough time to just finish off that line
of working and then you can write this
up heading and let me know when you're
ready by putting your eyes up okay so
excuse me let's have a think about this
some of the questions you've been doing
right you can see they have multiple
terms in them right so it's not just oh
I've got X to the power of n like X to
the power of five there's eight X to the
power of five and then this I can plus
another guy and plus another guy or
subtract another guy so what we gonna do
is establish the rule for when you're
dealing with a function that is the sum
of two other functions okay so we can
call this one the sum of functions okay
so let's think about this right suppose
you've got f of X not just being some
solitary X the power N or something like
that but what if you've got a couple of
other terms and a couple of other
functions within that something plus
something plus something so in order to
deal with these I'm just going to give
them some names okay so I'm going to for
example say that my my big function
whatever I'm dealing with let's say it's
made up of two smaller functions called
G and H okay now what I'm going to think
about is how would first principals
tell me how to deal with this object one
of these invested so much time in
learning first principles even though
you're like oh I've learned to rule now
I don't need to use first principle you
know it takes forever right the reason
we learnt it anyway is because that's
your foundation if you don't have this
idea you don't really know it's just
guesswork or you're just accepting a
rule someone else told you you don't
really know why the rule works so now
we're gonna use first principles on this
thing it will take some time but then
you can know without a shadow down not
just because mrs. Lee's and I tell you
not just cuz the textbook tells you you
can see the reasoning let's consider f
dash X as first principles this is to go
back to the original one our regular one
we were a little more comfortable with
its age approaching zero and then can
someone recite for me
what is the difference question for f of
X f of X we usually we usually say X
plus I should point out you actually can
write x minus if you want it still ends
up being the same thing but we won't
worry about that a new form for now it's
the other way around
right we're taking the difference right
so it's - go back to your diagram it's
in our diagram right we're taking the
difference difference question between
the top and the bottom values what did
the denominator become just H very good
there's no plus or minus mean to screw
up here okay excellent now if no it's I
mean the best things there artist grew
up with the better it is right if f of X
thanks guys we could go if f of X by
definition I'm saying it's made up with
two other functions then I can write all
of this stuff out just in longer form I
can break it into its like component
sections so I'm gonna write this as
limit as H approaches 0 of okay take a
deep breath instead of say f of X plus h
I'm going to substitute X plus h
everywhere I saw X so I'm gonna write
like so G of X plus h plus h of X plus h
do not like my H here is just the name
of a function which is actually
different to this register pretty much
yeah good question so I'm I'm just
dealing with this first term here yeah
that guy right so by a definition what
that means is everywhere you saw X which
at the moment is here and here
replace that with an X plus h is that
okay okay
staying with you alright so there that's
the first part and then what follows
minus f of X which is this whole entire
thing
right so I'm going to write that as I'm
gonna do it in big square brackets there
we go there's my gross-looking long you
read up but it's done okay all of that
is divided by H sad alright so far so
good
okay now here's the thing that's
important about this look closely at
this numerator right you've seen before
like when we were factorizing quadratics
and stuff like that sometimes it's very
helpful just to real
range something and you can see it in a
more helpful way the way I'm going to
rearrange it is I'm going to pair up the
G's with G's and H's with hitches okay
so here here's this function of G and
this function of G let's just write
those two and put them together beside
each other we can see them a little more
clearly okay so here we go
limit as H approaches 0 of I've got G of
X plus h that's the first function G and
then take away G of X that's what I have
forever there so far so good
yeah ok so I'm just going to put that to
one side we're going to serve justice
leave a large gap here for reasons it'll
become clear in a second and now that
I've dealt with the G's I'm going to do
with the HS that part of the function so
here is the first part and then there's
a minus that applies to everything
inside these brackets right so I'm going
to say minus H of X like that so far so
good now this entire thing is all over H
now do you agree with that the entire
thing is oh all over H but what I'm
going to do is I'm going to break this
apart into two fractions this over H and
this also over H is that alright now put
your pens down and carefully of what
we've just written okay see this guy for
instance over here right if I replace
these two G's with an F if I replace the
two G's with an F then wouldn't that be
exactly what this line says here like
it's it's literally identical except
there are G's instead of F's there right
which means that what you've got written
over here is first principles but for
the function G by itself does that make
sense this is the difference question
not for f of X but for G of X so
therefore this part here this entire
thing including the limit it is by
definition its G - that's that's what
this whole thing is okay what about this
have a look the limit also applies to
this by the way it's one big set of
brackets okay it's all the same stuff
it's the same difference question by
definition just I've got nature's it's
just the name of
function right so therefore that by
definition is the derivative of H H -
okay so what I'm saying here is F - the
way that I would summarize this the way
that I got taught to remember is the
derivative derivative of a sum is the
sum of the derivatives let me say that
again the derivative of a sum this thing
here is me taking a G in an H and then
differentiating altogether is the same
as taking each of those separately and
then adding them back together right
Dhruva the sum is the sum of the
derivatives okay so that's why when
you've been having a look at these
subsequent questions and you're like ah
Chris there's like an X to the 4 and a 3
X 2 squared plus however whatever stuff
is over here right you essentially can
say what this is telling you is just
treat each one individually and then off
you go okay